I'll go back to peers organization
England tonight lost a thrilling first
Ash's test match to Australia I'm
absolutely gutted about it but despite
that I remain adamant the cricket is
indisputably the greatest sport of all
many Australians will agree especially
tonight for many of our viewers in the
United States well they wouldn't agree
in fact they think Cricket is one of the
most boring confusing and pointless
Sports ever invented here are some of
our American friends watching Cricket
for the very first time
so the pitcher is trying to hit these
sticks maybe y'all Dead catching the
ball with their hands is the ball is
soft
what just happened
what just happened off his leg up in the
air he knows it's coming at him
I think in the back they throw the ball
like underhand I think this is the most
complicated sport I ever seen bro
that's the key we made it deliberately
complicated so Americans wouldn't want
to play it think about that when I was
stupid over here so is Cricket the
greatest sport in the world as I believe
or are we Brits and Aussies and a few
other countries just completely Bonkers
to debate this I'm joined by the bar
stool Sports founder Dave Portnoy in the
United States and from Yorkshire former
England cricket player umpire coach and
living legend David Bumble Lloyd all
right Dave poorly uh you obviously don't
don't get Cricket that might be your
problem not ours because Cricket is the
greatest sport ever invented
listen uh Pierce I thought there's a
misprint on the sheet when they said
what you were asking me to talk about I
Cricket I mean I've seen five seconds of
cricket my whole life I'm not against
Cricket I just don't care about Cricket
uh I just heard the introduction you
gave to the the guy in the panel I mean
if he was walking down the street and
slapped me in the face I'd have no idea
who he was I just don't know anything
about Cricket I've seen the highlights I
know that you can play for like 3 000
hours straight it seems interesting if
you know what's going on but it's not an
American sport it's our version of
baseball but yeah I don't care about
Cricket at all oh you're not gonna get
me to trash Cricket but I don't know
anything about it all right David Lloyd
enthused the gentleman explain why he's
so wrong to be so disinterested
because I'm not surprised that they
don't get it in America I really don't
and baseball's been mentioned and that
goes right above me America what is it
football they play when they're all you
can't tell anybody they've all got hats
on they've all got shoulders on and they
throw it around in fact they bring the
crowd in there can have a go as well so
don't talk about crickets the greatest
sport has ever been I'm not surprised in
the slightest look who's running the
country
well Davey's got a point I mean you've
got a you've got a present at the moment
who's I don't know what that point is I
well I'll tell you what the point is you
have to argue I don't I don't care about
Cricket no I if crickets here or there
nowhere again I thought it was amazing
let me try and let me try and explain to
you let me try and explain to you why
you should you guys are the ones who
need the respect for Cricket
who cares about crickets we're
explaining why you're wrong it's not
about the point of this segment well I'm
telling you the point of the segment so
get this little fact about cricket
cricket matches were played by soldiers
during the American Revolutionary War
with many games being played at the
Valley Forge encampment George
Washington I'm sure you've heard of him
also paid at least one game there with
the sport referred to as Wicket by
Americans at the time not the first time
you've taken our language and mangled it
um so cricket was very much there at the
start what happened why did you move to
baseball which is so clearly that speaks
volumes about
that speaks volumes about cricket being
boring if you're saying we had it all
these years we developed better Sports
more I mean people people play the cross
way back in the day and it didn't grow I
don't know I didn't know this turned
into we got the Fourth of July around
the corner and you got me coming at
Cricket for I'll tell you I'll tell you
one thing that is dumb can't the same
guy pitch every time
no that's the whole point that's why off
you can't go underhand can't the same
picture
no we don't play underhand anything all
throw it we don't do that we bowl and we
have great fielding positions like
sitting here
right no we we all together all right
you want me to say crickets great
crickets great I don't care Cricket's
great great go Cricket I don't all right
they go to any sport they've got a few
golfers are there any good at snooker or
darts
[Laughter]
what is it again again
snooker is rather like all over the
world baseball well
is this is this show only in Sydney
Australia or something I don't even know
what we're talking about it does air in
Sydney but snooker rather like Cricket
is to baseball is a sophisticated
version of pool we basically have more
Superior sophisticated intelligent sport
here probably why you don't like them
though cool
we're talking about pool now yes
all right I mean I don't know that you
got world-class athletes playing pool
but
well Dave Dave for those who don't
understand Cricket in America and care
even less and just think it's a waste of
time I always explain how could you not
enjoy that well hang on it's just not an
American story I'm actually talking to
the other David here hang on David Lloyd
the legend Bumble will call you um I was
explained to Americans that take the
ashes it's five matches
spreader each one over five days each
day can be seven to eight hours you can
get 200 hours of cricket and at the end
the score might be zero zero and that's
why we devised it like that so Americans
would never want to play it
well it's coming to America if you
listen to everybody about T20 which is
the dumbest form of the game T20 he's
quick he's fast it's lightning and it's
coming to America whether it be like it
or not it's on its way yeah it is and
Dave portney I'm afraid you are going to
grow to love Cricket you're going to
want to come on here every week and do
Cricket segments
I don't know what he just said crickets
come into America where at the local
YMCA is coming to cities All Over
America the three-hour version we could
introduce you to football and rugby as
well you're no good at that
rugby
you don't look familiar I just you guys
are trying to make me like a cricket
hater I just don't know much about it
the way you just described it you said
it goes on for seven days straight with
no points and no goals that sounds like
a torture captain
uh look two Dave's with very different
opinions about Cricket I have to say
David Lloyd for me Cricket has brought
me more Joys as I know it has for you
than anything else probably in my entire
life with a possible exception of how
because you're an Arsenal fan well
certainly more joy sustain Joy than
Arsenal and probably as much joy as a
hand-pumped part of Harvey's bitter
which I know uh David Lloyd you you love
a bit of bitter as well don't you I do
indeed and and we're gonna have to get
older Dave we'll take him to a map
he'll have to come kick in and screaming
for seven days we'll play it for seven
days
we have a date David Portnoy we're going
to take you to a cricket match and we're
gonna bore you into submission
to Superior form of baseball uh to date
two Davis thank you both very much
indeed for an enlightening debate we've
got absolutely nowhere but it was very
funny thank you both very much